The answer is five. Three for the location and two for the direction. You might
be tempted to answer six with three for the direction. If you think about how a
[UNKNOWN]
works the sensor can be given in altitude and a swivel angle to specify
direction. Just two values. A third value would be needed for the distance in a
given direction, but our eyes detect just radiance, not distance. It's an
interesting way to think of the universe. Just five numbers specify the
location and direction, and only need then is the radiance. Put together enough
radiance readings for a given location and set of directions and you get an
image. It's also informative to think how the radiance values change as you
move around. For example, if our sensor is in deep outer space, moving even
large distances will cause only small changes in the radiance values received.
Having insight into how a scene's light field changes can help us figure out
how best we can compute and store these changes to simulate it